okay thank you
[Music]
4 30 in the morning mumbai india
just came in from ukraine all nighter
zero sleep so the plan is today to
show you guys the first impressions of
this dynamic crazy place
here we go here we go we're into it
hello hello
taxi yeah
you ready yes let's do this
okay new brand british style my friend
yeah british style
okay you coming too
no service with service okay
okay tip yeah bro you didn't do anything
guessing you didn't do anything no
problem okay
[Music]
[Applause]
got a couple hours of sleep and i'm out
in the
urban jungle and so guys what i want to
do is just
take you on a walking tour no
no it's so loud
no tight agenda but just to show you
what it's like on the streets here in
mumbai
it feels very industrious first first
feeling i'd say it's like a
it's a hustle here it's a grinder
[Music]
so much stimulation so much energy
so many colors sounds smells
it's just in your face hardcore
super hardcore but
it flows
water water yeah
absolutely out of control
out of control for me in control for the
locals this is how it is
this i was just told is called the char
bazaar
and believe it or not it's much calmer
over here
looks like a lot of recycled
things like fans tools
speakers
[Music]
we're in the recycled car section
everything's just getting taken apart
[Music]
there's a part of the city i was told
about that has all this open-air laundry
so i gotta make some ground and get in
one of these taxis
toby got ah that's what we got
i
[Music]
many muslims here though right okay
many muslims in this neighborhood
[Music]
this place is called joby got it's been
in
operation for 140 years this open-air
laundry and they're roughly 7
000 people a day working here washing
clothes
so just wow my way around it looks like
you can get in
to this place
i just found a local here mamu who's
going to
take us through so right now we're in
the mahalakshmi laundry the biggest
laundry initially
the biggest launch in asia wow this
laundry was built like 140 years back
by the british people one box is for one
family
and in one box like five to ten
employees work one employs from normally
10 to 14 hours a day
so each and every person has got its own
customers belonging to hotels
hospital railways local areas so all the
mumbai laundry they come here
and every day we wash one hundred
thousand pieces of clothes
from here so the people who work here
delicious
they live here okay they live here so
the people in there can we go in
yeah so these are the houses okay
they cook here and sleep there yeah
yeah and then four to five five to ten
people lives in one house
so one year these people they works here
and after making some money they go back
to village to see their families
oh so the the workers here are from the
village nicely so their families
in the village they're getting like
indian money eight thousand nine
thousand rupees
so these are the technology nowadays
people are bringing more technology
so in technology you can bring more
customers and you can save your time and
energy yeah so your machines now such as
so it looks like there are a lot of
different contracts here so he was
saying with hotels
with different businesses this is
all new denim that was made here
in india and before it gets exported
they do a pre-wash here and after
pre-wash all this book they export
all export
now
[Music]
this is for the boiling the clothes from
the hospital sterilization
uh-huh they boil in a hot water
soda
and also the cloth coming from the
railways
uniforms okay which are mixed with oil
wow yes you're crazy this iron is with
charcoal this one is six kilograms
and these guys have two hundred two
hundred and fifty clothes every day
on one floor we get one rupee why use
charcoal
because we find better it is better
iron's better and he got the habit to
doing with the charcoal
you don't need the electric something
electric but you like the charcoal he
likes the charcoal he is he's a
traditionalist
oh yeah and the charcoal it does it adds
to the heat a little bit huh
in here how long do they stay usually
one year that
works here two years and after back they
go to the village to see the families
so the each and every clothe is one and
that going to the right person
okay so how long does it usually take if
someone has their feet
in the morning the day after tomorrow
you get it back before no technology for
people walking like this
blah blah
[Music]
is
i know
[Music]
uh
me
[Music]
so
nice
[Applause]
who's
give it to me bro give it to me yeah
thank you sir
yeah thank you nice to meet you nice to
meet you yeah
you are here for uh tourism tourism yeah
okay guys bye bye bye here on marine
drive yeah brother
[Music]
feel they are very hot and like the
summer seasons okay so we come here for
the refresh
and now we like a cool breeze start
thinking about the
mumbai by thinking about mumbai i was
just gonna talk about that so
yeah first day is today yeah
yeah i slept like two hours last night
two hours
yeah it's a crazy place it's very um
this is what i was gonna tell the
audience but i'll tell you guys too
yeah it's everything it's everything
it's like
so many people so much action so many
colors
so much flavor so much chaos so much
sadness so much beauty
yeah it's crazy man so what uh what the
most think you like here
you guys you you guys you guys i thought
we guys yeah
why why because you're the people you're
cool
yeah ready we are very eco perfect
friendly people
yes i know i just scratched
scratched the surface today i know that
wasn't a full tour of mumbai by any
stretch
thanks for watching like and subscribe
if you want to support this channel
hit the notification bell to get my
latest videos many more on india
pakistan and other countries in the
world coming soon
thanks for being part of this journey